these
are shade balls they're being dumped
into this water reservoir in los
angeles and contrary to what you may
have heard
their main purpose is not to reduce
evaporation
so what are they really for to find out
i'm visiting the largest collection of
these balls anywhere on earth
at la reservoir
96 million shade balls that's correct
96 million it's it's very rare for you
to see 96 million of anything
this is your life vest which you are
required to wear all right
throw a leg over and climb on in any way
you can
there you go looking at this
i had so many questions like why are
they black
are they safe to have in drinking water
how much do they cost
do they actually reduce evaporation and
what is their real purpose
is it hard to drive in shade balls it is
very hard why is that
these are actually partially filled with
water and the re the reason they're
filled with water is that
at la reservoir we have some really high
winds and so uh you know if we didn't
put water in these things there'd be
balls down to bouncing on the five
freeways people drive down they'd be all
over the place
so uh so these keep the balls in the
reservoir and if they do start to roll
they kind of wobble because the water
makes them uneven but that makes them
significantly more difficult to push out
of the way
especially when they form close packed
crystal-like structures
behind the boat the balls quickly come
together in our wake
and some close to the motor are pulled
along with the boat
wow
did you what did you think the first
time they suggested doing this or
when it when it first came in yeah it
was a little out there
did you think they were nuts no not nuts
well it just it like it looks absurd
it's like we're in the world's biggest
ball pit
right yeah that's what it looks like
yeah you would you can't tell by
standing here that we're actually
floating
over i think it's probably 40
40 feet right here 40 50 feet deep below
us
and we you can't even see any water
you'd think it was a joke right like if
you didn't know
you'd be like no you're not that's
you're a green screen or something right
yeah it's fake
so like when i switch on my tap at home
is the water coming from here yes
sometimes
or always most of the time most of the
time the water's coming from here
absolutely nuts so why is la reservoir
covered
in shade balls well the problem all
started with bromide
bromide is a naturally occurring
substance
it's associated with salt water and so
normally
places like the california aqueduct that
comes down from the delta
you get some salt water intrusion she
has some bromide in the water bro
bites harmless and it's almost
impossible to remove um but when you
when you disinfect the water with ozone
that bromide becomes bromate
and bromate's carcinogenic and so around
the year 2000 they wrote regulations
uh regulating bromate and the
regulations basically said if you have a
treatment plant that uses ozone
then you have to watch your bromate
formation be careful not to form too
much
so the only place we ever measured
bromate was at our filter plant
and the results were always within the
10 micrograms per liter limit
set by regulators so they were confused
when they got a call from one of their
customers a beverage company in la
they said we have some really high
levels of bromate showing up are you
aware of this
and we said well we don't show anything
but between the filtration plant and the
customer
was the reservoir so they did some tests
almost immediately upon coming into this
open reservoir the
the bromate levels jumped it turned out
that
bromide with chlorine which was supposed
to be safe in bright sunlight
formed bromate even more than ozone did
and so we made this
unfortunate scientific discovery that
actually was not part of any regulatory
scheme
and so here we are at the reservoir we
have water source that's got bromide and
harmless we have chlorine we have to
have the disinfectant water
and we have sunlight because it's open
the only choice we have is to remove
sunlight so
we looked at all sorts of things we
looked at floating
tarps across the water and normally you
put a floating cover on the water but
that's a
multi-year project and so we said well
can we manufacture these kind of
trampolines with poly like pvc pipe
and we said well i think it's going to
become bird perches it'll have a big
water quality problem
and so then we we knew we had uh
high-density polyethylene pipe which is
used in the water industry
and and we know that it floats we at one
point thought about can we just float a
pile of pipe across the surface well
that's
hard to do and very expensive because
it's a lot of material so maybe we could
take some pipe and run into a chipper
and we can make a
debris field across the surface like the
back corner of a lake somewhere
but then you have all this mushy warm
water with plastic floating on the top
that sounds like a petri dish
and so lo and behold dr brian white did
some research and he
and he found the shade ball
except they weren't called shade balls
at the time
this product existed and they were
called bird balls
and they used it on on ponds that had
mine tailings where they didn't want
waterfowl to go in and get poisoned
and also around airports where there
were ponds and they wanted to keep the
waterfall off so that they didn't take
off and get into jet engines
you know they've actually done wind
tunnel testing and they had you know
blew
you know 50 60 mile an hour winds across
to see how they behave
but they're really made to deter birds
and wildlife from sitting on the water
did there used to be birds landing here
more
like absolutely yes yeah once we
deployed these balls all the birds were
gone
they used to just hang out right loiter
at the curbs
yeah they'd be all over the top of the
dam
they'd be down at the the outlet tower
they'd be everywhere but we don't get
them anymore like we used to
but before being added to the reservoir
the shade balls had to be tested
would they actually reduce the formation
of bromate and we bought
three kiddie pools three little
inflatable kiddie pools and we filled
them all with the reservoir water
one was in the sunlight when we put a
tarp on when we put shade balls on
and amazingly the shea balls knocked out
the problem immediately
so the reason shade balls are black is
to block all light from reaching the
water and triggering the bromate
reaction
the black pigment is also safe for
contact with drinking water and it's
stable even exposed to the elements for
years
they're black for a reason so you know
they're made out of high density
polyethylene it's the same material
that like a gallon milk jug is made out
of it's a food grade plastic
and and they would be clear like milk
carton except that they wouldn't last in
the sun
and so they have a material called
carbon black in them and that's what
makes the
the plastic last for at least 10 years
out of the sun we did test to see
if there's any other colors we could use
so we actually had the company make
uh three different shades of blue but
the dyes were so unstable they said
we can't guarantee it's going to last
more than a year and so it's that carbon
black this is the magic powder in this
that really makes this product last in
the sunlight one of the concerns that
that
people raised to be when we first put
these on uh was that are they going to
get hot and the leech material out
and they don't they're totally a nerd i
mean theoretically you could cut off a
piece of this ball
and you could chew it no harm come to
you this is this is totally food grade
nothing wrong with it whatsoever what's
it like driving through these things
it's difficult as you can see we've been
sitting here for well i don't know how
long
quite a while and there's a breeze and
we haven't moved i mean anybody that
knows that's been on a boat in a lake if
there's a slight breeze and you're on a
boat you're drifting right
not here this thing that they're just
stable
that you it's interesting when you try
to pilot the boat through these things
it's difficult
it's like driving through peanut butter
or something something i guess yeah
not that i've ever done that but
blocking sunlight from the reservoir
also provided additional benefits
you know one of the reasons we put so
much chlorine in was to control the
algae growth but sometimes you still
couldn't control it
there were times years ago in the summer
where if we had an
algae outbreak you might actually if you
fill the bathtub up it might have a
slight tinge of green
i mean it may be healthy to drink but it
might have a slight change of cream from
the outside
yeah and it's just discoloring the water
that no longer occurs so uh with the
sunlight gone
um the algae problem is gone and we put
in basically no chlorine we've only had
a few times since the shade ball has
been on la reservoir that we've added
any chlorine at all
and we used to do half the chlorine in
the whole whole water system went into
that reservoir
just to control algae growth but the big
concern i had was
evaporation when i first heard about
these black plastic balls reducing
evaporation
it didn't seem to make any sense i mean
wouldn't they absorb more energy and so
heat up the water leading to faster
evaporation
it turns out the answer is no for a
number of reasons
in an open reservoir there is more
exposed surface area where water
molecules can escape
into the air plus there is greater
airflow over the water surface
continually removing the layer of moist
air and replacing it with drier air
increasing evaporation now the shade
balls do
absorb more energy and get hotter on top
but the bottom of the balls
stays cool plus the balls contain mostly
air which is a good thermal insulator
and so not much of the heat is
transferred through to the water it's
almost like a double pane window you get
that air gap in there
and the air acts as an insulator and so
the sun never hits the water
matter of fact we've actually done some
measurements and it's actually cooler
under the shea balls even though they're
black
than it is without the balls just with
the sun itself so so the balls actually
have a slight cooling effect
so for all of these reasons shade balls
reduce evaporation by 80 to 90 percent
that's pretty significant for a dry
climate like los angeles
how much do they cost these run about
around three for a dollar i think we
paid 33 34 cents a piece something in
that range
so and they and they actually have a
salvage value not that much but
if we go to remove them they're
recyclable material so
but but we figured that over the life of
the balls
um between the savings and chlorination
and the chemical savings and the savings
and evaporation probably at least half
the cost of the balls will be paid for
and so i mean of course the water
quality benefit is immeasurable but even
the balls themselves will save money
doing what they do
do you ever bring people out here for
tours or they're the first one
why am i the first one to get to go on a
tour here to get this uh level of detail
tour yes this is so cool i've heard
something about
hexagonal balls have you heard anything
about hexagonal balls
oh my gosh so we had the shade balls and
of course everyone in the world came up
with
another product i have ones i call this
the ravioli it's a small hex
we had large hexes we had all sorts of
pieces and people say well they lock
together but the problem is
they need to not stack up and they need
to not sit on the bank of the reservoir
the reservoir is going to go up and down
and so it's really the shape of the ball
that that makes them
not not perched on the side because we
need to make sure that these
when the water goes up and down that
they spread up or they you know it's
been spread out completely to cover the
water as best possible
i mean i just can't get over what i'm
seeing it's just so nuts i'm waiting for
you to say it looks like a pull of boba
[Laughter]
i feel like that's the line that'll go
in but you you got it
that's awesome
do you like bobo i love boba
i might get some after this
you